what's going on guys the new trailer for
Batman V Superman dawn of Justice has
dropped and we're here to talk about it
break it down tell you our thoughts got
a pretty cool group of dudes to do it
first
you know from black nerd comedy and his
new show mega movie get together on a
screen junkies plus Andre black nerd
meadows thank you for being here and
he's an old pal he's the writer of
Batwoman Wonder Woman 77 mark and Draco
and ah you know him you love him it's
our old friend Dan Merle it's it's night
time the trial just came out we are
burning the midnight oil to stay here
talk about it because you demanded we
service our fans in so many ways wait
that doesn't sound right what do we
think about this trailers are impossible
to judge movies buy great trailers can
be for horrible movies sounds like
you're doing a little damage control
that works out I do what you like about
it I liked a lot about the trailer I
like getting to see Batman and Superman
aura interact I like Amy see Clark
interact with Bruce Wayne I like this
you know I like the look of the movie I
like the Wonder Woman stuff I think I
did like the comic-con trailer better I
think because I feel like it was a lot
of shots to get me excited about the
movie but still kind of ambiguous to
what was going on where I feel like this
was very much the here's the scene where
Bruce Wayne and Clark Kent mate
here's a scene where Lex Luthor is in
between them here's the scene where they
fight here's a scene where in and out
together here's this scene one woman
shows up here to see more dudes each
other so I feel like it's almost kind of
is going a little bit of beat and as the
resident DC hater on the panel which is
not true by the way I Marc brought up a
very important point which is no you
cannot judge the movie by the trailer
was why these videos are called trailer
reaction videos we're reacting to the
trailer let me say this about the
trailer I'm with you that comic-con
trailer that they made I thought was
actually a perfect trailer I don't know
why anyone would complain about it from
Comic Con the comment on trailer this is
moot God for a movie about Batman V
Superman so now it's like Batman V
Superman V doomsday V Wonder Woman and
it's like it's a movie called Batman V
Superman they've shown us Batman V
Superman and they've shown us after that
we've seen now that they're teaming up I
think the trailer made a big mistake by
showing us after Batman V Superman
because now we're not invested in the
fight but yellows it might have
from hede sense to say spoiler alert
they make up but how do they yeah we saw
those production stills of the
bald-headed serious Lex Luthor in the
trailer he seems like just a little too
far
in his behavior she wouldn't have hours
long so we saw 35 seconds maximum hold
I'm just saying I did not love Jesse
Eisenberg but Jesse Eisenberg's playing
Mark Zuckerberg again and he's playing
that internet douchey smug entitled
Waddy kid I don't know he's playing Lex
Luthor son apparently he's playing Lex
Luthor jr. okay so see that's their
thing I think yes his performance in
that trailer is annoying but I think
that's the point he's supposed to be
this Punk inherited wealth kid that has
never won for anything and thus nothing
means anything to him that makes him
sense but do you think there's going to
be a point where that does progress into
a more dark more oh yeah yeah I feel
like I feel like we're seeing phase one
of Lex in this trailer and and hopefully
there's a whole there's a whole other
side that we're going to see or maybe
this is his performance in public when
behind closed doors
it's though it's the more sinister side
I hope so granted it's a two and a half
minutes snippet right but again we're
talking about the trailer and I think
it's a very questionable choice it'd be
like putting dancing emo Peter Parker in
the trailer for spider-man 3 Oh kind of
being out of character and that's him
like not and he has a whole other level
to his character
that's why would you put that because
yeah you made an extreme choice with
[ __ ] trailers you now twice shown Lex
Luthor Jesse Eisenberg playing this
character like he's playing him like
Edward nygma from the TV show Gotham
like I'm with you market you can't judge
the entire performance based on this you
absolutely can't but I love these they
they are if it's not the performance
that Jesse Eisenberg is giving I think
they're making very curious choices and
what they're showing us it is what it is
I will say that that first scene where
he's just like Clark KITT
oh what a [ __ ] I'd hate to have to beat
this guy till superhero movies are known
for their subtle yeah Elmo sick
cody's Jojo I want to throw a couple of
other things out there and get your
thoughts what did we think of doomsday
making an appearance the look of the
character and the opposing forces kind
of squaring off there a lot of trailers
including Terminator Genisys including a
lot they feel compelled to give away the
act 3 villain in the trailer and and you
have one of the best concepts of all
time for a comic book movie which is
Batman V Superman oh yeah again just
from a trailer standpoint I don't know
why you feel compelled to give that away
Batman is pissed at Superman because of
the destruction of Metropolis it comes
out of retirement they fight Luthor
manipulates both of them into hating
each other then they realize they've
been manipulated Luthor's like oh
they're going to come kick my ass so I
need to make this big monster thing and
then Wonder Woman shows up I don't think
it's that hidden we now know what each
act of this movie is going to be yeah
that's what I'd like
then I don't like pear that - force
awakens where we don't know anything
about the Luke Skywalker's the bad guy
one thing we haven't touched on yet and
the appearance of Wonder Woman in this
trailer yeah how do we feel about the
way that was handled again I feel like
we know how she's gonna be introduced in
the movie now and instead of wondering
how she's gonna be introduced now we've
seen her big hero shot mm-hmm maybe know
she's you can tell about the other
trailer you see Batman knows her he
might not know that Diana Prince is
Wonder Woman right but yeah this is
probably her hero shot but but also -
since the Wonder Woman movie is taking
place in world war 1 she's been around
for a while so how they're gonna explain
all that will be pretty interesting as
well also I wasn't the biggest fan about
just the wat walk she with you I thought
she was with you
hmm and the context of the movie I'm
sure that's probably really funny yes
and the comedy in this is just as dumped
in my opinion is the comedy in the
Marvel movies I don't
I want comedy to be organic I don't need
hey I don't like that yeah whatever I
don't think it's a trailer made for the
fans I think the trailer at San Diego
was the one made for the fans this was
made for your parents when you get them
to go see ya this is like did you hear
about the super things and the people
who are up watching Jimmy Kimmel yeah
now I'd love to go down the line get
some final thoughts on the trailer and
your thoughts going into this movie
trailer was fine probably to reveal too
much definitely
Comic Con trailer more but already going
to see this movie and not going to
compare it to any other franchise
compare his own thing and shut up if
you're saying you're not going to see
because you are I'm excited for this
movie I liked Man of Steel I think I
like where the DC Cinematic Universe is
going I don't think this trailer was
made for fans I think this was
predestined to be for the average
American not for the fan because the
fans know all this stuff already
right on I appreciate that Dan there was
some stuff I did like I like I like the
Batman or the Bruce Wayne Clark Kent
back and forth of the beginning yeah my
cities had not had a lot of success with
with psychos dressed like clowns I liked
that I actually liked all the Batman
Superman stuff in the trailer my main
qualms just gave away way too much did
it give away too much what do you think
leave us your thoughts in the comments
section below we want to know the
coolest answer we're gonna send you a
screen junkies t-shirt I want to thank
you for watching and I want to thank my
awesome panel you guys broke it down
like champions Andre Meadows black nerd
comedy thank you for being here mark and
Draco always a pleasure
dan Morelle hey always pleasure to see
you around the office exactly
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter
thanks again for watching bye bye
no Spidey which is strange because he's
the center of the comic book storyline I
wouldn't mind if they chewed spider-man
like Luke Skywalker this was coming
hashtag where theater hashtag repeater